Have you ever been waiting in line at the grocery store,...
...innocently perusing the magazine rack, when a song pops into your head?
Not the whole song, but a fragment of it that plays and replays...
...until you find yourself unloading the vegetables in time to the beat.
You've been struck by an earworm, and you're not alone.
Over 90% of people are plagued by earworms at least once a week,...
...and about a quarter of people experience them several times a day.
They tend to burrow in during tasks that don't require much attention,...
...say, when waiting on water to boil or a traffic light to change.
This phenomenon is one of the mind's great mysteries.
Scientists don't know exactly why it's so easy for tunes to get stuck in our heads.